est-ce que vous connaissez la voiture de
film d'horreur la Skoda ferate c'est un
mélange entre d'un côté K2000 Christine
avec des faux airs de Batmobile en fait
c'est une voiture qui a eu un grand
succès en République tchèque dans les
années 80 parce qu'elle est apparue dans
le film youzed Ferrato qui veut dire
tout simplement le vampire de Ferhat
dans lequel cette voiture marchait au
sang humain et elle veut les pomper
directement le sang de sa victime grâce
à la d'accélérateur et ça donnait
au conducteur un immense plaisir de
conduire j'ai pu monter dedans le truc
qui est génial déjà c'est que vous voyez
on a tout l'habitacle qui se lève et
vous vous venez vous faxer dedans faxer
littéralement parce que on est vraiment
très à l'étroit et quand le toit vient
se fermer on a l'impression que ça vient
vous taper le crâne c'est donc une deux
places une propulsion et surtout avec
une carrosserie en fibre de verre parce
qu'à la base c'était une bagnole qui
devait aller faire des rallyes alors moi
j'adore ce look il y a pas de Far
rétractable comme on le voit dans les
années 80 avec notamment K2000 kits mais
à l'arrière le design est incroyable
avec cette énorme rond une carrosserie
qui est perforée d'ailleurs dites-moi
vous ce que vous en pensez est-ce que
vous aimeriez faire un tour cette
bagnole quitte à vous faire aspirer le
sang par la d'accélérateur
marquez moi ça dans les commentaires